in a certain part of Academy City in the
middle of the night a white-haired boy
known as accelerator is filling his
shopping cart with an unusually
excessive amount of black coffee cans
after getting outside of the store he is
met by a group of delinquents who tries
to attack him though obviously to no
avail he mentions to himself that since
his defeat in the hands of Toma he is no
longer considered the strongest in
Academy City even though his powers
still remain and that he is still a
level five while walking he passes by a
certain apartment complex and is annoyed
by the noise created by two certain
characters he uses his Vector powers to
mute out any sound for him as he
continues to walk alone however
unbeknownst to him he is being followed
by someone after a while the person
comes close enough to him for him to
notice and uses his Vector powers to
unmute sound with this accelerator
discovers that is from a voice of a
little girl who calls herself masaka
twice annoyed by her accelerator
continues to walk along ignoring the
girl though she continues to try and
talk to him telling him that she has
been trying to get him to notice her all
this time suddenly accelerator remembers
the name misaka accelerator removes The
Claw from the girl himself and sees that
the girl is completely naked making her
cry the girl says that she is the twenty
thousand and first clone to be produced
for the sister's project and says that
her code name is last order she
continues by saying that since the
experiment has been nullified she was
apparently released from her tank in the
middle of the incubation process as is
the reason why she appears so small in
comparison to the other clones last
order states that since accelerator has
connections with the researchers she
could use him to contact them for her
accelerator gives an immediate response
to her that he is not interested which
somewhat disappoints last order since
she has nowhere else to go
apparently feeling sorry for her
accelerator lets last order follow him
to his apartment building when they get
to his room they discover that
accelerator's room has been trashed
still uncaring and yet somewhat
expecting of this accelerator lays down
his purchases and proceeds to sleep on a
relatively intact couch to rest last
order happy goes and why on accelerators
surprisingly intact bed and warns him
not to touch her in the middle of the
night much to accelerator's annoyance
morning shines through the curtains of
accelerator's room as he awakens from
his Slumber here he discovers that last
order is still in his room and is hungry
ask an accelerator to cook some food
accelerator and last order go to a
restaurant for their breakfast while
last order happily asks herself what
meal to get accelerator notices a person
in a white lab coat outside of the
restaurant parking lot it is a my
according to accelerator who was
wondering what he is doing there Amaya
notices accelerator's gaze and quickly
gets into his car to try and vacate the
premises while eating accelerator
reminds last order of what he did to the
clones
hearing their conversation turning
serious last order stops eating and
responds to accelerator last order
states that since she is connected to
all the Clones she of course knows last
order states that she was taught the
value of being a clone and even if a
single clone dies there's no way the
entire mazaka network would disappear
last order says that without accelerator
the experiment would never have been
proposed and that Souls would have never
been injected into the lifeless mazaka
clone and she thanks accelerator for it
thinking that last order is joking
accelerator smirks and reminds her that
he enjoyed killing the Clones however
last order counters by saying that
accelerator is lying and says that
accelerator didn't want to do the
experiment in the first place
accelerator gets mad at her observation
and says that the fact that he kept
continuing with the experiment means
that he thought nothing of the clone's
lives
accelerator stands up to leave however
after turning his back he discovers that
last order has been overcome with
something
last order states that she in a
condition where her body is incomplete
as such her current condition
accelerator walks in familiar places for
a while and arrives at a research
institute in a dimly lit and messy room
with several computers running since a
woman
she reminds accelerator that he didn't
need to break the down the entrance as
his ID card is still valid accelerator
later asks yashikawa Kiku where the
experimental body adjustment manual for
the Sisters is accelerator asks about
last order Kiku explains saying that the
special experimental instance known as
the last order she states that last
order was never made to be a part of the
experiment to begin with the point of
his sisters was to be killed by
accelerator and that it requires having
twenty thousand battles for the
experiment to finish
he continues and says that last order is
not part of the experiment but is the
command center of the misaka network
that is the reason why her development
has been held up and why she took care
of her even after the experiments was
terminated
kikyu however states that seven days ago
someone has Overworld her program of
malicious code because of the effect of
the malicious code last order ran away
from their laboratory as a response
continues by saying that the virus will
activate tonight which would spread and
infect through the misaka network and
will make it go out of control where
they'll initiate an indiscriminate
attack against all humans hearing this
accelerator only laughs at the
interesting situation and asks who the
suspect is
states that the most likely culprit is
Amai which surprises accelerator after
remembering his strange behavior in the
restaurant parking lot she tells that
there are two things he can choose to do
now capture Amai and force him to talk
about the virus structure and resolve
the incident or secure last order who
Bears the virus in her mind and put her
back into the incubation tank the scene
cuts to accelerator running in the
streets of Academy City grasping in his
hands last order personality files
accelerator arrives at the place here he
is told that a man a white coat is taken
away last order accelerator contact kick
you and report to her about the
situation accelerator asks why am I oh
would take last order if the virus
activating would occur even without
doing anything knowing that amay is
still inside the city accelerator smirks
and states that humans actions become
more simplistic when they lose their
comfort zones with that accelerator Cuts
kick you off and proceeds to find out
where a May meanwhile near an abandoned
research facility a mysteriously out of
place yellow car sits in Desolation
besides him his last order of breathing
heavily and having electrodes stuck to
her with a notebook computer on her lap
monitoring her condition he pleased to
last order to be alive at least until
after the virus gets activated suddenly
an omen of Doom appears before a May
slowly coming towards him in black and
smiling as the accelerator out of sheer
Terror Amai tries to desperately start
his car he floors his car towards the
still smiling accelerator however it is
all for nothing as accelerator's Powers
easily crumbles his car making sure that
last order is safe in the process
smiling still accelerator taunts Amaya
asking how he should play with him amay
desperately tries to get out of his car
but is stopped by accelerator who tells
him to calm down a mile later faints
seeing last order's current state
accelerator asks if they can stop the
virus using only the equipment of my has
Kiku however States that is not possible
as to override the virus they would need
a specialized incubation tank and a
testament machine
during the conversation however
accelerator begins to notice a distinct
sound coming from kiku's line here Kiki
reveals that she is heading towards
where accelerator is using a car as it
would save more time and reveals that
she has finished 80 of the analysis of
the virus code infecting last order and
that she'll make it by midnight suddenly
a voice can be heard from last order and
starts to speak in gibberish and moving
erratically almost instantaneously
several warning signs begin to pop up on
the notebook computer screen concern
accelerator asks Kiki what's going on
hearing last orders ramble over the line
kikyu concludes that the virus has begun
its preparations to activate and states
that the leaked information that the
virus will be activating on 12 midnight
was probably a red herring
with alarms going off he carefully says
to accelerator that he is the only the
one who is able to save the situation KQ
tells him the most obvious and only
single thing he could do in this
situation the elimination of last order
suddenly accelerator realizes something
and contacts Kiki regarding it having
last orders personality file before the
virus infection accelerator asks since
he can control brain cells is there a
possibility that he can manipulate last
order's personality files realizing his
plans kick you asks accelerator if he is
planning to use him and his powers as a
substitute for a testament machine she
tells he can't accelerator however
disagrees with her and states that if he
can use reflect redirect then he can
also be able to manipulate and plugs in
the USB containing last order's data
file into the portable digital Kiku
continues to argue with accelerator but
he ignores her and throws away his phone
using the portable digital terminal
device accelerator completely memorizes
last order's data file before her
infection with the virus and concludes
that he will just simply get rid of all
the code and last order's brain that
doesn't match the previous data file and
say that it is a piece of cake
after destroying the portable digital
terminal device accelerator touches last
order's forehead with faki begins his
operation accelerator compares the
pre-infection date to the data within
last order's head however he realizes
that if he gets rid of all the code then
last order would be restored to her
State the week prior the week before she
met him he executes the command to
destroy the mismatch code using his
powers and slowly the warning messages
on the notebook computer disappear one
by one
last order begins to respond to
accelerators tampering as she starts
spouting random words and codes and
moving erratically as well while erasing
the code's accelerator Ponders to
himself what he's erasing along with the
virus and concludes that it is better
for her to forget anyway suddenly as if
on Q Amaya regains Consciousness and
points a gun towards accelerator telling
him not to interfere accelerator is
gripped with fear for the first for
having a gun pointed at him he has used
up all his processing power in order to
delete the virus inside of last order's
mind and doesn't have the computational
capacity left for a redirection
accelerator reflects with himself he
could take his hand off last order as so
he can regain a capacity for a
reflection which would then make him
Invincible he doesn't and is shot by
Amai in the middle of his work lamenting
on how he was too native of the thought
that he a villain could save someone and
start all over again
having shot the accelerator on my last
maniacally for having brought down the
strongest esper with a gun and still
living however his laughing stops as
soon as last order announces that the
code that Amai injected into last order
has code break error code due to the
error last order deems that the
processing of the command to be sent to
the misaka network where it would force
the sisters to attack humans has been
aborted seeing the failure of his
operations Amai points a gun at the
unconscious last order
angered that his fears were correct Amai
fires the handgun suddenly a hand
emerges and manages to protect last
order reflecting the bullet back towards
a maze handgun destroying it and
injuring his hand
writhing in pain Amaya turns his head
and sees his worst fears come to
fruition the accelerator has survived
and has managed to compute a reflection
right before the bullet reached his
brain accelerator emerges holding the
gaping and bleed hole in his head and
gives his Sinister smile however
accelerator finally succumbs to his
wounds and falls to the ground seeing
accelerator fall to the ground a mai
reluctantly checks his body and
concludes that he has indeed not moving
and with his powers not working with
that Ahmed takes another gun from his
lab coat and points it at accelerator he
mocks accelerator saying that in the end
he didn't have the ability to finish off
jobs just like Heroes and states that
they are rotten regardless then a small
gunshot rang out and a man began to
bleed here a woman named yoshikawa Kiku
holds a small pistol with her
she was the one who shot Amai having
been shot am I fall down once again
takes the naked and unconscious last
order in the back of her car where an
incubation tank awaits her a man comes
to once again and tries to sit up
however he sees Kiku Loom over him she
aims and pulls back the hammer of her
pistol ready to shoot to kill amay Kiku
continues on by saying that I may need
not worry about accelerator as he knows
someone special amongst his
acquaintances a person with frog face
though he is called the Heaven cansler
by people is someone who'd still save
accelerator's life Kiki then points her
gun on a maze chest however at the same
time as this of my pulls out his gun and
points it at kiku's own chest as well
Kiki regains Consciousness and discovers
that she is in a hospital of a certain
frog-faced doctor the heaven cansler
here Kiki was surprised that she has
survived to which the frog-faced doctor
rhetorically asks who she thinks
performed the surgery Kiku states that
she thought that she was shot in the
heart of point-blank range to which the
fraud-faced doctor corrects her by
saying it was actually a coronary artery
extending from the heart however he
states that she was pretty much dead on
the spot if it not for the efforts of
that kid the accelerator the frog-faced
doctor continues by saying that
accelerator has sustained damage to his
frontal lobe and has had his language
and computational ability affected
hearing this Kiki tries to ask if it
affects accelerator's ability as well
however the frog-faced doctor cuts her
off saying that making something work
that is not working anymore is his
policy before leaving the heaven
Chancellor asks what she's going to do
now as the higher ups found out about
the incident and has finally closed down
the research facility and the experiment
completely terminated
she was fired hearing this kick you is
disheartened that she can't live as a
researcher anymore the winds pass by and
moves the curtains of a certain hospital
where a certain white-haired boy wearing
a collar is sleeping sound lead while
the Girl by the name of last order is
beside his bed sleeping as well
yashikawa Kiku is there as well as
yamakawa iho the latter asking the
former to confirm if they are the one
that she will be taking care of to which
Kiku says yes then the sliming doors are
opened and they turn to look the frog
face doctor smiling at them the end be
sure to subscribe and hit the
notification Bell to not miss these
certain scientific accelerator next